[Musik]
seit meinem ersten besuch bei tatjana
carolina vor drei jahren scheint die
zeit stehen geblieben zu sein
und ich frage mich was wenn wir das wohl
unserer liebsten vertrauensvoll in
gottes hände legen und bald erkennen
müssen dass die winde des schicksals
unbeeindruckt weiter gehen
darum geht es in diesem film
[Musik]
drei jahre vorher in der agglomeration
der ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew
wer hier aufwächst dem stehen im leben
nur wenige türen offen
marina carolina hatte das schon früh
verstanden und entschieden verfügung die
stirn zu bieten
[Musik]
marina carolina hatte träume und während
sie darauf warten dass diese in
erfüllung gehen würden passierte ihr das
leben
[Musik]
ein leben das immer mehr eine art
amalgam wurde aus dem was sie lebte und
aus dem was sie und ihre mutter sich
vorstellten
marina tust du hier nur alles andere
machte sie im wohnzimmer vor dem großen
spiegel ihr aussehen war ihr sehr
wichtig sie hatte zb wunderschöne haare
es gefiel mir dabei zuzuschauen wie sich
zurecht macht wie sie sich frisierte wie
sie sich schminkt und wie sie
verschiedene kleider anprobiert das war
viren fest für mich ich liebte diese
momente damit kann marina kalorien ab
2005 nach hause das sei ein vertrag
erklärte sie ihre mutter sie gehe in die
schweiz und werde ort ist in für 2303
franken im monat in der ukraine ein
jahreslohn was erzählte marina nach
ihrer rückkehr über ihre zeit in der
schweiz
sie sagte sie liebe die schweiz warten
sie ich zeige ihnen was dieses bild hat
sie mir aus der schweiz mitgebracht
das ist meine marina so viel schönheit
wie in der schweiz habe sie noch
nirgendwo gesehen sein
immer wenn die mutter wissen wollte was
eine art ist ihm eigentlich genau macht
wurde die tochter wütend und es gab
streit bis die mutter irgendwann nicht
mehr fragte
[Musik]
hat jana karin assmann lich wir davon
aus marina 14 war unterhalt erhielt sie
nie erst als ihre tochter begann als
artistin in die schweiz zu reisen konnte
die familie anfangen sich mehr als das
nötigste zu leisten ja plötzlich war
sogar geld da um eine kleine
eigentumswohnung an zu zahlen
[Musik]
endlich ein silberstreif am horizont ist
eines morgens ein polizist vor der tür
stand und sagte ihre tochter sei tot
mehr wie sehr auch nicht auf wiedersehen
nicht gott sondern ein mensch wollte
marina ist ein mensch der nicht viel
überlegt obwohl er selber vier kinder
hat dachte er keinen moment daran dass
meine tochter auch eine familie hat dass
sie eine mutter hat die um sie weinen
wird das war weder zufall noch schicksal
das war mord
nicht mehr und nicht weniger einfach
mord es war in der nacht auf samstag den
november 2008 morgens um 4 uhr als sich
marina kalorien aus wörter auf den weg
machte murat k kaufte unterwegs einen
kanister und füllte ihn mit zehn litern
benzin
damit und mit der absicht zu töten
vorher zum cabaret moulin rouge in augst
im kanton basel-landschaft und legte
feuer
[Musik]
bereits der einkauf im supermarkt ist
für tatjana carina heute ein
finanzieller kraftakt
sie arbeitet bei der lokalen verwaltung
und verdient 120 franken im monat
das muss für zwei personen reichen für
sie und ihren 17 jährigen sohn aus ihrer
zweiten ehe auch jener mann ist dir
davon gelaufen
auch er zahlte bis heute nie unterhalt
und trotzdem muss jeden tag etwas zu
essen auf den tisch
nicht
ich weiß nicht wie es weitergehen soll
ich kaufe es ihr spaß am einen immer nur
kleine mengen im sommer pflanze ich
gemüse an und konserviere es für den
winter aber gewisse dinge muss ich
trotzdem hier einkaufen
ich drehe jede münze zweimal in der hand
um bevor ich sie aus gebe aber mein
portemonnaie ist ende monat immer leer
hat ja nach kaluga musste nach dem tod
ihrer tochter irgendwie weiter
funktionieren obwohl sie die vergangenen
jahre wie in einem nebel erlebte wie und
warum ihre tochter ums leben kam wusste
sie all die jahre nicht die ukrainische
botschaft in der schweiz welche die
kommunikation zwischen den schweizer
behörden und den hinterbliebenen hätte
sicherstellen sollen aus dem fall
offenkundig wenig priorität bei das gibt
darin dass eines tages vom flughafen
angerufen wurde
es sei ein paket für die familie
angekommen mehr wisse man auch nicht es
war die urne
als sie sich beim außenministerium in
kiew beschwert habe habe man ihr
beschieden man habe weiß gott anderes zu
tun als sich um die belange einer toten
note zu kümmern
ihrem leben gab einzig das so nach sinn
und struktur mit dingen wie dem
abendbrot rasierten tag für ihn
zubereitet
[Musik]
alexander war zwölf als seine
halbschwester starb um den verlust zu
verarbeiten hat er angefangen leute zu
schreiben
in meinen texten geht es darum was ich
jeden tag in den straßen meiner stadt
erleben was ich für gefühle hatte in den
letzten vier jahren alles was geschehen
ist was ich für sorgen hatte ich
schreibe über alles was mir passiert ich
schaue zum beispiel aus dem fenster und
sehe die blätter fallen und erinnere
mich daran wie ich mit meiner schwester
spazierte als sind dann überkommen mich
gefühle und ich setze mich hin und
schreibe darüber
[Musik]
alexander macht eine lehre als
automechaniker obwohl in dieser beruf
überhaupt nicht interessiert in der
schule haben sie herausgefunden dass er
hoch begabt ist aber für ein studium für
der mutter das geld
natürlich hätte ich andere träume für
mein leben aber die ukraine ist kein
land für träume brachte hass und
eifersucht liebe murat k in jener nacht
richtung augst
das kostete drei tänzerinnen das leben
einer marokkanerin eine russin unter
30-jährigen ukrainerin maria kaluza
der täter konnte bereits tags darauf
festgenommen werden und wurde inzwischen
wegen dreifachen mordes zu einer
lebenslänglichen freiheitsstrafe
verurteilt
alters höheren marina kalorien aus
angehörige vier jahre nach der tat zum
ersten mal von mir
[Musik]
auch dass der kanton der kanton basel
landschaft an bietet ihnen eine
genugtuung in der höhe von 35.000
franken zu zahlen erfährt die familie
von mir
die ukrainische botschaft in der schweiz
hat den entsprechenden brief nicht
weitergeleitet
ich habe bei der schweizer vertretung in
kiew einen termin für die familie
vereinbart wenn das vertrauen in die
ukrainischen behörden haben tatjana
kalina und ihr sohn alexander
mittlerweile vollständig verloren und
weil maria kaluza in der schweiz stark
möchten sie den schweizer botschafter
bieten ihnen dabei zu helfen zu ihrem
recht zu kommen
mit der genugtuung von 35.000 franken
könnte die familie ihre hypothek bei der
bank bezahlen und wäre endlich die
quälende angst los ihre bescheidene
eigentumswohnung baut zu verlieren
erzählt tatjana carolina er sei
eigentlich nur für die interessen von
schweizer bürgern in der ukraine
zuständig sagt der botschafter
es tue ihm leid aber er müsse sich
zurückverweisen und yuca ihnen behörden
ökologie da muss ich aus jesus mensch t
umland und das haben wir besprochen
miteinander
was ich aber roboter haben ist dass mir
vor der botschaft der usa geben
sensibilisiert für den fall dass ich
jetzt neu den nächsten tagen note
schieber als ministerium und sie
informieren über die über den fall
über die kontakte nicht kann und wo
nicht so verbissen bewegt maßnahme
briefe
er steht der familie fortan für alle
fragen zur verfügung versichert mir der
botschafter und er werde alles tun damit
die entsprechenden formalitäten in den
kommenden monaten erledigt seien
andernfalls verfällt der anspruch auf
die genugtuung nämlich
[Musik]
fast drei jahre später treffen hat jana
kaluga wieder
sie lebt immer noch in der gleichen
wohnung am stadtrand von kiew ihr sohn
alexander sitzt immer noch am gleichen
computer und doch hat das leben der
beiden seither eine neue richtung
genommen
dank dem geld aus der schweiz dass sie
mittlerweile bekommen haben
ich habe meine lehre abgebrochen und ein
studium an der universität angefangen
ich lerne jetzt einen beruf der mich
wirklich interessiert ich studiere
internationales recht und werde anwalt
ich denke so kann ich künftig die
interessen meiner familie und die
interessen anderer die meine hilfe
brauchen schützen
außerdem hat alexandra jetzt eine
freundin christina eine medizinstudentin
aus odessa
[Musik]
als das geld aus der schweiz 1 traf
schien die talsohle durchschritten zu
sein und eine bessere zukunft nur eine
armlänge entfernt hat jana kalina und
ihr sohn investierten einen teil der
genugtuung in eine wohnung in einem
neubau es sollte ein anfang sein für
alexanders leben mit einer eigenen
familie
aber das schicksal wollte es einmal mehr
anders das land versank im chaos und die
wohnung ist seit über einem jahr eine
bauruine alexander der bald 20 jahre und
hier irgendwann seine eigenen kinder
groß ziehen wollte nimmt auch diesen
rückschlag
mit stoischer gelassenheit zur kenntnis
seit ich denken kann war ich der einzige
mann in der familie von mir wurde immer
erwartet dass ich stark bin also wurde
ich stark ich tue nicht nur so ich
glaube wirklich dass alles gut kommt
wenn man so viel erlebt hat wirft einen
nicht so schnell etwas aus der bahn
werden
gleichzeitig weiß ich natürlich dass
meine mutter mich weiter braucht darum
lächle ich manchmal auch einfach weil
ich sehe dass das meine mutter
zuversicht gibt und sie glücklich macht
ende 2013 aus die meisten proteste
begonnen hatte alexanders optimismus
nichts aufgesetztes er und seine freunde
marschierten an vorderster front mit mit
der tiefen überzeugung dass es möglich
war die ukraine richtung europa zu
öffnen ein europa das für fortschritt
und chancen stand
ich denke wir sind auf dem richtigen weg
aber im moment ist die ernüchterung groß
wir haben nicht den eindruck dass sich
unser leben zum positiven verändert hat
im gegenteil es wurde eher schwieriger
keiner von ihnen hätte sich vorstellen
können welche kettenreaktion die
proteste auf dem majdan auslösen würden
das plötzlich schüsse fallen würden dass
das tote geben würde dass russland die
queen besetzen würde dass der osten des
landes in einen blutigen bürgerkrieg
versinken würde und dass die chance groß
sein würde was sie selber war 2006
kopiert und an vorderster front mit
kämpfen würden
wie viele ihrer kollegen die bereits
dort sind
meine familie stammt ursprünglich aus
der union was und wir haben dort noch
viele verwandte
darum ist für mich klar dass dieses
gebiet zur ukraine gehört und wenn es
sein muss sollten wir dafür kämpfen
gleichzeitig frage ich mich wieso die
regierung nur leute wie mich an die
front schickt wieso soll ich für unser
land sterben während die söhne der
minister und oligarchen irgendwo im
westen studieren und die nächte in
irgendwelchen clubs durch feiern
[Musik]
hat janka rubina ist zu ihrer mutter und
ihrer schwester aufs land gefahren zwei
autostunden aus rat von kiew
[Musik]
einmal mehr wird die familie den kalten
atem des schicksals im nacken
alexander wird in wenigen tagen 20
und es ist wohl nur noch eine frage der
zeit bis er auf dem schlachtfeld stehen
wird
[Musik]
ja alexander ist jetzt alt genug für die
armee natürlich mache ich mir deswegen
viele denn wenn man einen so tragischen
verlust erleben musste wie den meiner
enkelin marina dann ist es schwer auch
nur daran zu denken dass nun auch noch
alexander sterben könnte ich leide mit
allen kindern die in diesen sinnlosen
krieg müssen aber speziell mit meiner
familie
wissen sie ich habe auch noch einen
enkel in moskau um ihn habe ich angst
wieso passiert alters sind es die fehler
unserer politiker oder ist es gott der
sie geschehen lässt
ich weiß es nicht ich bin nur ein mensch
was kann ich wir können nur beten
ja wir können nur beten wenn die not am
größten ist zieht es tatjana kaluga in
diese kleine kirche hierher war sie
früher oft mit ihrer tochter gekommen
und die mutter ist sicher dass es marin
als letzter wunsch gewesen wäre dass
ihre sterblichen überreste hier ruhen
geschützt vor den winden des schicksals
nahe beim herrn
[Musik]
das marina kaluga in jener nacht
ermordet wurde war zufall
sie kannte murat k nicht und er sie ja
auch nicht
eigentlich hatte er es auf jemand
anderen abgesehen
genau drei monate zuvor war es eine
beziehung mit der besitzerin des
cabarets in die brüche gegangen und er
hatte nur noch einen wunsch gehabt sie
und alles was mit dir zu tun hatte zu
zerstören
seine ex geliebte war den flammen
allerdings entkommen
[Musik]
nein an gott habe ich nie gezweifelt
marinas tod war sicher nicht gottes
wille gottes wille wäre gewesen dass sie
liebt sie heiratet dass die kinder aber
ein mensch wollte es anders und jetzt
wäre es gottes wille dass mein sohn
alexander studiert und ein botschafter
des friedens wird
schauen sie sich meinen sohn an
er ist kein krieger alexander ist ein
poet der gedichte schreibt und daraus
musik macht er soll reisen und allen
zeigen dass es in der ukraine viele
talentierte menschen gibt die die welt
bereichern kann
gott hat ihn in dieser welt geschickt um
gutes zu tun
von sicher nicht damit er in den krieg
geht
und so endet mein besuch in der ukraine
mit der bangen frage ob diese geschichte
wirklich erst zu ende erzählt ist wenn
sie ihre schlimmstmögliche wendung
genommen hat